good afternoon welcome to introduction
to ml net my name is John Alexander
I'm a senior content developer on the
docs Microsoft comm team and I've been
working on ml net documentation code
samples things like that and I'm also
just kind of switched to team's
cognitive services Doc's team so today
we're going to talk a little bit about
this new framework that allows you to
infuse machine large machine learning
solutions inside of your applications so
come along won't you the jokes don't get
any better so might as well laugh now so
machine learning or learning itself or
diagnostic do you notice anything wrong
with that wrist or the bone right below
it there are some cracks in it right so
the Blue Mountains of Australia are
extremely formidable especially when
there's a rock in the trip so Monday I
was out on a tuber and we were going on
a small trail to an outlook not like
mail but you know looking looking out
for wait why am I talking about this
with ml net so I go in and there's a
pattern that I go to the hospital they
take a look they feel and they recognize
the pattern of this nasty-looking bruise
that was kind of starting to swell a
little bit and so they sent me to x-ray
it one or more data data came back with
a high probability of a break a fairly
high probability wouldn't you say
and so if you're going to break you know
your arm you want to kind of do it right
so it's a compound fracture but it
didn't it didn't go anywhere so that's
good so they said well Wow since uh John
you were foolish enough in your 20 years
of travel you've always bought travel
health insurance until this trip um
we're gonna stabilize you and you can
get it taken care of when you get back
to the states but they used the
information that they had and the model
inside their head to be able to
correctly identify what was going on in
that image in the same way we can use
the data that we have to answer the
questions about our business and in this
case the question was very simply is it
broken
got the data back and we could we could
do a high probability that it was so I
won't warn you that because of that I'm
on some pretty good pain medication at
the moment so this could be very and in
in some pain so I apologize if it's not
at my usual level of presenting but I
wanted to go ahead I mean I was even
telling them at the hospital man I got
to do this presentation I'm here for the
conference I've come all this way
just cut the arm off it'll be fine okay
so anyway though we have to be able to
answer questions so how many of you
would consider yourselves dotnet
developers of some form or fashion okay
yeah you might have built things for the
cloud you might have built things for
the web for the desktop maybe even a
mobile app or something cool for the
Xbox might even have done something with
an Arduino now unless we were going to
get into either pre-built models or have
a high amount of knowledge to use things
like the cognitive the CNT K the - okay
okay before that we didn't have a decent
answer to be able to start using machine
learning in our applications but before
we talk about what ml net really is
let's take a step back like we're
programming the unprogrammed Bowl so if
we look at this question is this a face
well yeah right I mean duh
and that's a universal I think that's a
universal sentiment you can say duh
wherever you go sure how do you build a
function to answer that question
maybe a lot of if statements right so
huh so how do we build a function to do
that
what about based on a description
figuring out the price of a shirt you
might be able to use keywords something
like that but how does it how would that
scale if you could do that so one of the
things we have is a tremendous amount of
data sitting around I guess I need to
stay by the microphone so I apologize we
have a tremendous amount of data sitting
around that we can utilize to create a
model that recognizes the pattern of a
face or not a face based on example
after example after example after
example after example you get where
that's going right so it really isn't
about the code necessarily anymore it's
about how we handle that data and what
we do with that so there are many
machine learning 10 there are many many
things that machine learning can answer
for us and we can kind of classify those
down and we're going to focus today on
three of those first off is how do we
classify something is it binary is it a
or b is it multi class how do we
classify something sentiment analysis is
this a positive or negative in my
Twitter feed you know
die you scum might be considered
negative great job positive but there
are then there are things in between so
how much how many how much is that shirt
can we predict that price what's the
weather going to be on Tuesday
that's a regression problem we're trying
to figure out based on be the series
that we have what's coming what comes
next in that series and then another one
is we've got a bunch of stuff that we
need to organize how can we do that like
maybe topics and in for news items in a
news feed and that's what we'd call
clustering so you may have already
started playing around with machine
learning with cognitive services I think
there's about 90 different services
right now that you can utilize and use
different models already to be able to
handle things object classification and
vision pulling out speech recognition
translation all sorts of different
things
you could even do sentiment analysis
using that as well with text analytics
so if we look at this we're sending in
sentiment what do you think guys and
ladies positive or negative positive
great vacuum cleaner so we've sent that
send that in and it comes back 19 96
percent positive okay sure
that's great we can use that all day
long so that so we're going along and it
works well then all of a sudden we get
this
it's a positive or negative you and I
know based on context that it's probably
positive right based on a pre trained
model though it sees sucks it doesn't
recognize the fact the context of that's
what a vacuum cleaner does right it
sucks a lot of dirt like a Dyson or
something like that so we get that back
and that's nine percent positive so what
do we do about that well pre-built
models can take his a long way they can
help us to build several different types
of applications but at a certain point
we may need to use and train our own
models or get a model and import that in
from our group of data scientists or
somewhere else and be able to use that
with our data so that's where we come in
to ml net so thinking about building
your own models and the first thing we
need to do once again is come up with
the question that we're trying to solve
what is that question you guys seen the
matrix it's the question that haunts us
right what is the matrix what question
are you trying what what can you answer
based on the data that you have so we
can prepare that data we can make sure
it's clean we can do what's called
feature izing that and pulling in
different combining different columns
all sorts of things so that we can
better answer that question once we do
that we pull in the data then we can
build and train that model but if you
notice there with those arrows that's an
iterative process we look at that model
we train it
we look at the metrics go back and we
tweak it again train it some more and so
on and so forth until finally the
metrics say that we have a good enough a
good enough model and we go ahead and
deploy that to production put that into
a Web API utilize that utilize it in an
in an application of some sort mobile
whatever and we go from there so today
we're going to talk about solving three
different problems with ml net we're
going to talk about issue classification
in github and the problem is around what
area what technical area does this
particular issue belong to is it
security is it i/o is it HTTP client
what might that be so we need to figure
out how to label that with issue
classification recommendation you might
need to build into an application a
service to recommend something and we'll
take a look at how we might build that
with ml net and finally we'll take a
look at in this release with the image
classification capabilities that we have
in the point five or Elise and we're
going to try to determine whether or not
this is a dog okay
so what is ml net ml net is a framework
that's made for dotnet developers it
allows you to build your own model and
it allows you to focus on things such as
like we talked about sentiment analysis
predictive predictive analysis all sorts
of different things that you might that
you might want to do there it's proven
and extensible and you say John it just
came out how can it be proven and
extensible okay I'll take your cynicism
that's a fair question
it's been used by Microsoft internally
for about 10 years and if you've used
recently anything in office like for
example the PowerPoint design ideas if
you've used that or chart ideas in Excel
it's based on the EMA what ml dotnet
engine on the back excuse me in the back
end it's also open source it is open and
it's cross platform you can run it in
Windows or in Mac or Linux
you
come on
so this is the machine learning repo and
there's several different things here
one of which is you can see all the
source code as it's being built and
we're currently on the 0.5 or release
right now on our way to 1.0 there are
some different internal docks in here
there are also some samples and some
tests we'll take a look at that in just
a moment
so we'll tell we'll get in get in more
to that in just a few minutes so like I
said ml dotnet is a framework and it
allows you to go from something with
cognitive services where you might be
using pre-built services into building
your own model into and it's a built
based on a code first approach so that
you can utilize many different aspects
of the API finally one of the things
that's kind of unique to ml net is the
fact that you can save the model
asynchronously into a zip file and then
pull it back in into another application
so okay we've got Python we got our
anybody here use Python we're here use
our
can you spell are okay they're great
there's nothing wrong with them at all I
love Python it's cool
but as a.net developer it's it's really
challenging for me to be able to create
a machine learning solution so we want
something that we can use natively okay
so currently we have our API is split
out into two different areas one for
training and one for consumption and so
you need to be able when you pull in
data to be able to transform that so for
example on a text transform you'd want
to pull that in for data processing
you'd want to be able to change that
around do all sorts of things to break
that text up in certain ways pull out
different words maybe for example all
sorts of things you might need to do
with text you may need to also combine
things or handle categories in a special
way if categorical transforms will allow
you to do that all sorts of different
transforms we have different learners
that we can use whether that be linear
or something like k-means for clustering
and we have the misc category every
framework has that so basically when
you're needing to actually load the data
whether that be text or image or
something else you can do that it also
has several different API s for
evaluating based on the learner that you
have to bring back metrics that you can
use to verify the validity of that model
and then finally it's extensible one of
the first extension extensions that
we're utilizing is being able to pull in
a tensor flow model and use that
directly within ml net and we'll see an
example of that we can also right now
export to onyx which is a an open source
community framework that allows you to
share models back and forth from
different languages so like I said
before this has been used for quite a
while at Microsoft in Bing ads for
predictions for chart recommendations
for design ideas in PowerPoint even in
Windows 10 for Windows Defender several
different things okay so we announced a
point one in at build and since then
we've added clustering recommendation
that we'll take a look at and tensorflow
the first steps in tensorflow support we
have the ability to do more validation
through cross validation to be able to
make sure that our models are what they
are doing what we think that they should
do we have different transforms for for
example scoring that tensorflow model
when i'm working with something like
tensorflow and my images I get back a
score or a percentage of confidence on
what I found in that in that image is it
an orange is it an apple what what am I
looking for
in that image what am i pulling out of
it is it a is it a digit additional
learners so that you can now we have
what's called an ensemble learner so you
can actually combine different learners
so you might want to do a classification
regression and pull that into the
pipeline itself as I said there's a
support for onyx now which is that
community based open-source model that's
supported by Facebook Microsoft and
several others we also have improved
f-sharp support now we within ml net I
believe point four we can we have
support for a direct f-sharp record
handling in that and then finally there
is the machine learning samples repo
there are several different samples out
there including a lot of the stuff that
I'm going to show you today so you can
use that to take a look at and get
started so let's jump into the first
example and this one is for um github
issue classification like I said before
in a repo like in in the.net core FX
repo you get a lot of issues all the
time
wouldn't it be nice it's almost like an
infomercial would it be nice if you
could go ahead and label that
automatically how much would you pay for
that
just wait you know so it's one way it's
one tangible example you can use for
machine learning so in this as I said
before if it's classification we're
looking is this err be but not only that
because we have more than two labels so
it's multi-class classification so which
label should this issue be assigned is
it a language is it something within the
operating system is it something even
buffering there's as you'll see when we
get started there's probably 30 labels
that it could that one of these could be
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and so here's an example right now
notice that we have different labels
here actually I'm gonna go out I'll just
go out to the repo let's do that
anything about the dotnet repos as they
all start with dotnet
[Music]
so let's go ahead I'm gonna turn up the
terms the font can you see that in the
back sir you see it okay cover your
other eye let's try that okay so let's
take a look at some issues and so now we
have several different issues that's
here and you can see that we have
several different areas here some for
memory some for security whatever that
might be so if we have a new if we have
a new issue we can then try to determine
or predict what that what that label
should be and if it says something like
I don't know
you know dotnet framework then the
labels probably broken a little bit okay
so let's go ahead and jump into that
sure no okay
so inside of ml nut we have a console
application here and inside of our
nougat package I've got several several
different api's that we can take
advantage of and in this case we're
going to be using several different
aspects of that so the first thing that
we do is we have what we would call a
pipeline and really the the metaphor for
the pipeline is similar to what we might
do with debugging where we want to keep
the context and everything together and
in this case um this well it's really
good to have a linear flow sometimes we
may want to decompose parts of that
pipeline and utilize that in different
ways pull out different trainers and use
the products of that in a different part
of the workflow currently we can't do
that so one of the things we are going
to see today is the changes that are
happening in the API as well but before
we get to that let's talk through the
concepts of how we would use this in our
in ml dotnet so the first thing we have
here is our learning pipeline then we
actually load the test or our training
data in and we also have a schema here
that we can use and so let's take a look
at that
if I scroll down to the bottom here here
is our github issue coming in I noticed
that we have the actual issue ID and the
label that we're going to utilize what's
the title of the issue and the
description and notice that we have
columns it's adorned with columns there
so that we can determine what position
those things are and we're gonna use
that then with our prediction to
determine what that area should be okay
so let's go through that shall we so I'm
gonna go ahead and start this up
okay so here in our pipeline
we can see that we have some rows built
in that's pretty small let me magnify
that real quick okay there we go
so as you can see here we can see that
schema there there's the ID the area
that we want to use or the information
we want to use to train our model the
type the title and then the description
so now that's thinking okay John that's
that's great we can see that so now we
want to take a look at that though and
see what happens next when we start to
when we start to transform that so the
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to create we're going to tell in
our pipeline that our area is our label
the thing we want to use to train this
model and so this is what we would call
supervised learning and supervised
learning basically well it doesn't
basically supervised learning has the
pattern that we want to teach or that we
want to train the model with inside the
data that we're using itself so that it
has an example that it can use to go
okay I understand this is a good if
we're talking in terms of like text
analysis or something like that it would
be this vacuum cleaner is great and that
would be would have a positive sentiment
next to it so on and so forth in this
case what area would all of this
historical data be attributed to okay so
let's go ahead and step into that
now let's take a look at this
there yeah
so we can see pull this up a little bit
and there's our label right there we're
going to utilize so basically what we
want to do is take the non-numeric
pieces of data and turn them into a
numeric equivalence because what we're
trying to do is figure out okay is this
close to what I'm trying to predict and
we do that with numbers and magic
okay so now let's go through and you
notice we had the title there let's take
a look at that and notice that we have
now with our Fiat text feature Iser
we've trade we've changed that title
into a representative set of numbers
once again so that we can then utilize
that to determine the percentages and
that's what the model is actually going
to use to train from and we call that a
numeric vector so where would you go to
find out more about machine learning
terms I don't know John
where would you go I'm glad you asked if
you get a doc stop Microsoft com
there's an ml net guide there and there
is a handy-dandy pocket-sized glossary
if you have a phone that will fit in
your pocket
so we go at down here and say okay what
is what is a feature so basically it's
breaking down that text into something
that we can measure it's trying to
measure the unmeasurable okay we can
measure a number right we may not be
able to measure a title of you know the
the link is broken in this document how
do you measure that so we take that and
we break that down into what we would
call a numeric vector there's all sorts
of fun terms so if you get if you're
having trouble sleeping late at night
you can poke the glossary with a glass
of warm milk and it will help but
seriously though we've tried to put a
pull in a bunch of different machine
learning terms because really the target
of this framework is for developers that
may not have had much exposure to
machine learning okay let's go back to
the code okay so now we're going to do
the same thing with our description
and now we can see that in place the
description we have another set we have
another vector there okay so the next
thing we're going to do is we're going
to add our trainer because we're going
to classify this as a multi class
classifier and then we're also going to
go through and tie in the predicted
label with our converter we'll see that
in just a second this is almost as fast
as running it normally I realize so once
we've done all that now we take the
issue that's coming in and this is our
input this is our output so we use that
to predict then we're also going to
write out the model asynchronously and
that would allow us to pull it back in
to utilize it and I don't know whatever
we would want it and as your web service
or pulling that into exporting that to
onyx using that then pulling that into
like core ml or something like that for
a phone you know using that inside of a
raspberry pi to measure discrepancies or
anomalies on a manufacturing floor or
something like that I mean you have that
model and that's really the expensive
part of the machine learning is training
that model okay
you want to do that there we go so we're
going through and while that's running
I'm going to walk through some more of
the code but basically we have some
different parameters that we can use
that are outside of the model itself
that allow us to tune what's going on
with the model and those are called
hyper parameters and so basically that
allows us to take that model and tweak
it in such a way that we can get more
performance out of it or make it more
efficient hyper parameters ask for it in
your grocers frozen food section so
basically we're going through and using
the classifier to determine and train
the model itself so the next thing we're
going to do is write that model out as a
zip file and then notice what we're
doing next we're simulating using this
in another in another application so
we're gonna read that in a synchronously
and then use some test data well I just
used a bunch of training data so what am
I gonna use for test data wouldn't I
just use that same data I mean the test
would look pretty good right if I use
the same data it's gonna look phenomenal
because I just trained on I'm like oh
yeah sure that's that's whatever I'm
trying to do that classifies perfectly
so what we want to do instead that can
cause if we if we would do that that
would cause a problem called overfitting
so basically overfitting means that
we're when we're creating our model
we're going to get a false sense of
correctness because we're using the same
data so it's a good practice on the data
set that you're using to train to take
about 20% of that split that out and use
that for testing so we can evaluate that
and see what the accuracy of the model
might be and what that also simulates
is the ability to you use historical
data to train our model and then use new
data as it comes in to test and evaluate
that or to actually use it in production
but making sure that we have the
accuracy that we need okay
so now we're going to use our text
loader once again to load in our tests
and remember we saw on the on the
framework diagram we have several
different evaluators that we can use in
this case since we're doing
classification that's a classification
evaluator that we can use and it's going
to return some metrics
come on
okay so it came back had a little bit of
an issue with some formatting but we
processed a little over three thousand
rows and evaluated that and so now we're
going to use one of the metrics called
micro accuracy but really it's more it's
more apt of a term to say it's a micro
average I'm not talking about little
bitty cars and how what the average size
of that is talking about micro average
would be how well each clap each area
performed as it went through the
training okay like for example like
system IO in that area or metadata or
whatever you know how are the individual
classes themselves how did they perform
and that gets aggregated up okay
so let's go ahead go ahead and predict
on the issue itself
and so we've got about 73% micro
accuracy there which isn't which isn't
bad so now we're going to go ahead and
take some sample data and predict on a
on a new github issue this case we've
got our title it assumes the results of
get get method will be not null
it sounds like a party game Trivial
Pursuit or something like that question
so we'll see what it determines that is
so let's go ahead and predict that
and it says
here we go this is the area it's system
dot link for that particular for that
particular issue okay
so that's actually being used today on
the repo the models being used to
determine what the labels are
so just a review we have two different
items of data that we're pulling in for
input that we're going to to take a look
at and those are our features its title
and description we're using our label to
train the model so that we know so the
model knows what to look for for
prediction so once again we take the
features and our label and we train that
and it outputs our model so we use the
prediction to go ahead and have our
predicted label so I talked a little bit
about this before and we just saw this
in the in the demo we load our data we
take our labels on our plain text and we
extract our features and change those
things that we really can't measure
easily into numeric values that we can
measure more easily we train our model
and the models the output we evaluate
that and any data scientist will tell
you that right here takes up a lot of
lot a lot a lot a lot nuts you know a
lot of time okay and that presupposes
that you've already gone through and
identified the data that you want and
the question that you can actually
answer okay so it's knowing your data
and then knowing what you're really
trying to answer to get to this point
okay because like I said before this is
a real iterative process to determine
whether or not you're really getting
back either what you think you should or
something totally different and you keep
using the evaluation to make sure that
that's right because once you get to
this point here to model consumption it
becomes way more expensive to pull that
back from production has anybody
experienced that that once you put the
model in production it's more expensive
to try to
pull that back then trying to really
tune that down kind of like what the
architect Frank Lloyd Wright said he
said I'd much rather use a pencil on the
drawing board than a sledgehammer on the
construction site so much less expensive
there okay so we talked a little bit
about classification let's talk a little
bit about movies who likes movies
anybody like movies okay
can everybody stand up it's afternoon
right learning right if you can just do
a little stretch we're gonna just
stretch up a little bit let's kind of
get loose you know it's the afternoon
okay good right okay
so favorite movies favorite movie
categories okay okay right so how can
you use machine learning to build
something that has a degree of
confidence that you can recommend to
somebody wouldn't you like to know the
answer to that kind of like how to buy
real estate with no money down stay
tuned okay
[Music]
so anybody watch netflix anybody like
the preview thing on netflix you know it
starts up immediately it's you know
anyway once again I'm on pain meds so I
apologize for the yeah okay one approach
that we can use
is population averages although I think
I'm using that word in a way it's not
split you know I do not think that word
means what you think it means
right how many have seen The Princess
Bride if you have it you should put it
on your bucket list it's a pretty pretty
interesting movie okay I mean it's got
an IDE IMDB rating of eight of greater
than 8.0
okay it's got Billy Crystal in it all
sorts of people that's great
all right but you can use population
averages to go hmm twenty million
thousand people 20 million thousand
sorry payments 20 million people really
liked that movie it was the feel-good
movie of the summer right that can kind
of work if people actually like it but
there's some flaws in that in that
approach because what what's the biggest
flaw in that approach that you can
probably see this is the interactive
part of the show
right what if you're not one of the the
people that thought it was right what if
you don't like this you know this movie
maybe yeah but I mean if we're trying to
if we're trying to give a recommendation
for you
you know population take you so far
okay content-based filtering do you like
Iron Man
do you like Captain America then you'll
love Iron Man - the second one not so
much
yeah those of you that's kind of an
inside joke those of you who have seen
how many of you would say that that
would be a valid recommendation that
you'd like Iron Man to would you okay
what about if we said okay you've seen
Iron Man you've seen Captain America
you've seen Hulk you've seen the first
Avengers the second Avengers um we think
you would like Notting Hill there since
it's broken with that but anyway we can
use content-based filtering you go okay
John really likes superhero movies and
so I'll recommend infinity war and he'll
willingly pay out his money and go see
it millions of times and get it on DVD
and watch it again
okay another approach that we can use is
collaborative filtering collaborative
filtering allows me to get a
recommendation based on what other
people who have similar likes or
dislikes like or dislike so these are
some of the people on our team ank it
likes them doesn't like the movie heat
doesn't like Mission Impossible the x's
mean don't like okay home alone
Terminator 2 didn't like Casino Royale
gal he liked heat Mission Impossible
didn't like home alone like Terminator 2
like Casino Royale John or c-czar either
one likes mission impossible liked heat
and actually this isn't true because I
did like home alone but for that might
be a different John Terminator 2 and
Casino Royale okay so basically the the
premises is that if person a has the
same opinions person B then a is more
likely to have B's opinion on a
different issue than a randomly chosen
person so the question once again we
come down to a question that we want to
answer one question right in this case
what's the probability of gal liking
casino ramp and so we released what's
called factorization machines that allow
you to do this type of analysis so in
this we picked you have to pick a data
set right to answer your question we
talked about that in this case we're
using the movie lens data set there are
twenty million ratings twenty seven
thousand movies across one hundred
thirty eight thousand users okay and it
provides you with the movie information
itself that has movie ID title at genre
and then user ID the movie ID the rating
they gave and a timestamp
okay so factorization machines is a
binary classification learner we talked
a little bit about binary classification
versus multi-class classification you
can say that three times fast so we have
to model this as a binary classification
problem and since the scale inside of
the movie length is one to five we've
got to come up with another way to do
that and so in this case it was decided
that if it's greater than three it's
recommended if it's less than three it's
not recommended okay so basically take
that rating and then change it to a
binary value that we can measure
so the essence of machine learning is
that we're trying to answer a question
based on data that we can accurately
measure to determine the validity of an
answer to that question that make sense
so basically we use numbers to determine
yes or no or what something particularly
is okay in its most basic form okay so
let's go over here this is a little bit
better than just let's walk through the
code but it was good to get the concepts
of seeing how we transform different
types of data into something that we can
measure and I keep saying that because
it is important okay
all right so in this in this solution
we've got a couple of different projects
one is actually helping us create the
model and the other one is letting us
what we would call operationalize that
or use it in production in this case
we've got an MVC project that's our
little movie site recommendation so
let's take a look at that first and then
we'll take a look at the code behind the
scenes hmm that's interesting
that's kind of hard to read all right
takes it a moment to load up so we've
got a movie recommend recommender right
now so does anybody remember what the
question is is that we're trying to
answer right
does gal like casino rap so let's go
into gal his current profile and notice
here we have some recently watched
movies all-time box-office movies and
click on the recommended and I ran this
in debug I didn't want to do that yet
let's go ahead didn't you yes continue
here we go okay notice here that the
recommendations faceoff is about 55%
home alone is about 30 Casino Royale is
84% Titanic 56 and gladiator is also in
the 80s okay
so if we remember correctly from our
from our graph CSR is a very similarly
he likes the same sort of movies so
let's see what the recommendations are
for him put that back on in a minute
and so here notice that Casino Royale is
87% their gladiator is 85 and they're
very similar now one of the things that
happened with this data is we created
this we kind of cheated a bit because if
you remember c-czar's already seen
casino rau
so we uploaded that for training
purposes okay
so now let's go ahead and see the magic
behind this
so we broke this into two parts let's
stop this real quick
so once again we have our build model
and we're loading our text again and in
this case we're using something new and
this is called a categorical hash
one-hot vectorizer so basically what
that does is allow me to take non
numeric information that we want to use
as categorical and create a vector that
we can use then to measure categorically
across different parts of the model so
we do that and we bring in our user ID
in our movie ID because the user liked
several different movies and a movie can
be in several different several
different genres then we take those and
we combine those into a column called
features that combines the numeric
vectors for those then we go ahead and
we use our learner and notice that we're
passing in several different parameters
to make that more efficient pulling in
our data just like we did before with
our actual data our user ID or movie ID
and this time we're going ahead and
identifying the label that we want to
use for prediction and then here's our
predicted label that we're going to use
as the output and we simply run that
through and get our metrics out and we
can see that I'm not going to run that
part right now because it's 20 million
records and it takes a little while okay
so we can massage or wrangle that data
though because remember it's a binary
classification part and we want to be
able to go ahead and use ones or zeros
but since we're on a five-part scale we
need to be able to break that out so
basically we're going through and
changing that rating as needed to either
1 or 0 creating our data set going ahead
and sorting that out and then here is
that part that I talked about where
we're splitting the data out part for
train and then another little part for
test so that we can use that effectively
okay and so that's creating the model
and then in our controller we go through
we bring in the user ID for our profile
we grab that profile we load the movie
recommendation model which is what we
used we built before in our other
application we go through and we set up
our matrix for our ratings our movie
ratings and our watched movies and then
we go through and we grab the watched
movies and make a prediction for that we
return that view
and the one thing that we do is we take
the rating that comes back and we make
it we convert that to a value between 0
and 100 using a sigmoid function that
we've created okay so we use that then
to use to recommend the movies okay and
then finally we have the image
classification that I'll show you real
quick and I have a data sheet that's
going to be coming out with a bunch of
different links and also the project's
them where the projects are themselves
okay let's do that real quick and the
slides will be available so I apologize
this has been a little disjointed
circumstances being what they may
and this will also be out in the samples
directory probably early next week
okay
so here we're using the inception model
and that has has been trained on about a
thousand different categories of images
that we can use to actually pull in an
image and determine what category it's
in okay we have a data file that has
several different images in it a shark a
puppy all sorts of different things we
go through and this is actually
utilizing the new API that allows us to
independently instead of linearly go
through and load that text up or that
text up via text loader notice that
we're loading our image path and then
down here we're creating after we've
read that in Westham ating that we're
creating an estimator that we're going
to use to Train in an estimate we're
loading it up as an image we're resizing
it and then we're extracting the pixels
we're then going through and using some
of the data for the tensorflow
model itself pulling that in and then
using the estimator to score the data
and what we mean by score then is that
you're going to get back a a number that
shows how confident you are that this is
a dog or or whatever you're looking for
okay so go through and we read all the
lines and then write out that label so
let's go ahead and try this so you can
see that and we're
so this one says that it's a great white
shark yes sorry about that so it is
shark that JPEG and I will go back and
do that
Oh sighs yeah you mean the sighs that's
it no there we go
it's done okay
all right I apologize but it did come
back and say that it was a great white
shark and we're done he said so if you
have other questions feel free to I'll
be around asked me any questions that
you want again I apologize if it was a
little disjointed I'm actually in a
tremendous amount of pain and I want to
pain meds right now so I hope it was at
least a little bit valuable to you and I
appreciate the time that you've spent
today so thanks a lot and if you have
any questions or want to see something a
little more detail I'll have the machine
and so I'm here for the next couple of
days so whatever you want okay thanks a
lot